auf und davon mit immobilien
versicherungen und vorsorge
[Applaus]
süße köstlichkeiten ohne ende auf dem
dessert festival in florida
1000 waffel herzen muss auswanderer mike
dafür heute backen doch ausgerechnet
jetzt wird seine frau marina krank
[Musik]
aber noch nicht lungenentzündung
im sonnigen florida eröffneten micro
städter und marina mara vor gut einem
jahr wir waschen restaurant
das geschäft mit dem süßgebäck lief gut
an aber die viele arbeit hinterließ
spuren mike schlitterte in ein burnout
geschäft mit notebooks
stopp zuviel des guten
von einem tag auf den anderen musste
marina dass waffen restaurant alleine
führen
in der hoffnung auf mehr profit wanderte
bauernfamilie visa nach frankreich aus
anderen branchen auf mich selber ihr
riesiger hof an der atlantikküste
forderte sie immer wieder aufs neue
auch so und sonntag der mit
besonders streng waren die tage während
der saison
trotz allem kam die neue französische
lebensart nicht zu kurz
in bella italia eröffneten phillips
weiter matti und partnerin eva dunkle
ein agriturismo aber kurz nach dem start
trennten sie sich
die beiden versuchten das projekt auf
freundschaftlicher basis weiter zu
führen
doch die finanzen und unterschiedliche
vorstellungen wurden zunehmend zum
problem
und als eine von evas töchtern zu besuch
kam brach der konflikt offen aus
den aufzogen
jahrhundert vorgestellt
[Musik]
in tampa florida beginnt ein neuer tag
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mitarbeiterin media öffnet den waffen
shop selbständig sie ist eine von sechs
teilzeitkräften die die auswanderer
mittlerweile beschäftigen
für mike und marina bedeutet das viel
weniger stress anstatt 100 stunden sind
sie nur noch 50 stunden pro woche im
laden
diese veränderung war notwendig denn
mike schlitterte vor neun monaten in ein
burnout
eine ganze
zwei monate lang konnte mike nicht
arbeiten seine energie war weg ihn
plagten verspannungen und panikattacken
gestoßen sein
oder überrascht
wie lange die zähne
zeigt von
dass sich das tier gestaltet und den
englisch jetzt hat einfach gelangt und
batterien
[Musik]
eine schwierige zeit auch für marina
auf ihren schultern lastete die ganze
verantwortung für das gemeinsame
business
journal heimische
schaffen und noch mehr schaffen damit
man mit arbeit herrscht doch eine spare
wo es halt mit drin klage war in 100%
versetzen und so die befürchtung
jetzt wo es mike wieder besser geht
sieht er die zeit gekommen neue pläne
umzusetzen
der 45 jährige möchte wieder tätowieren
schon in der schweiz betrieb er
nebenberuflich ein tattoo-studio
kurz stand bei ca und das geht ich sehr
für finanziell geht es ist stabilität
die bewilligungen dafür hat er bereits
eingeholt und auch schon ein ladenlokal
angemietet
heute kann er den raum beziehen
[Musik]
in derselben shopping mall wie ihr waffe
restaurant befindet sich auch das
zukünftige tattoo studio
max neue nachbarn kosmetik na'vi und
coiffeursalons
[Musik]
seine arbeitstage möchte mike von jetzt
an aufteilen einen halben tag wird er im
waffel shop sein die andere hälfte hier
im café restaurant soll mike durch
angestellte ersetzt werden
wahrscheinlich über die jahre alte
fahrer mit tata wir wussten irgendwer
sondern
als hobby ist aktiv geschafft
und
gehört
jetzt lang darauf gewartet dass ich
wirklich versteht das geht mir einfach
entspannend und berufen das ist ob axel
ganz
viel freude pur heißt das tätowieren
mike hilft seine balance zu finden würde
auch marina davon profitieren
[Musik]
in der toskana ist der herbst
angebrochen
[Musik]
die bauern in der region ernten die
oliven bei den auswanderern aber ist es
noch nicht so weit philipp hat sich mit
seinem gärtner massimo verabredet sie
wollen sehen wie sich die 800
olivenbäumchen entwickelt haben vor
einem halben jahr ließ philipp sie
pflanzen
die bäumchen musste philipp den ganzen
sommer über bewässern kleine jeder
andere stoff werden
auf gut deutsch zeit völlig
gegangen aber doch nicht dass ich so
einen schönen baum das ist geschichte
hin dass ich
zwei jahre alt sind
die olivenbäume sind wichtig für die
schweizer denn die einnahmen aus der
landwirtschaft müssen höher sein als aus
dem gäste betrieb nur so gelten sie als
agriturismo
doch für weitere investitionen in den
ackerbau fehlt momentan das geld
er wartet nur darauf dass ich ihm sage
du jetzt machen wir
nur im moment ist einfach eine person wo
alles blockiert und das ist ein riesen
frühstück
das geld ist zum reizthema zwischen
gutsverwalter philipp und kapitalgebern
ifa geworben die zusammenarbeit als
geschäftspartner wird je länger je
schwieriger die
ferienwohnungen konnte eva zwar
mittlerweile alle möblieren aber bei
fünf der sechs appartements fehlt noch
die küche und den kauf mit einem kredit
finanzieren kommt für ifa im gegensatz
zu philipp nicht in frage ich meine ich
bisher bin ich muss das könne wieder
zurückzahlen
muss nach einem foul auf
die fehlenden küchen will sich eva von
ihrem verdienst als kindergarten
lehrerin absparen philipp möchte rasch
geliehenes geld investieren die
vorstellungen der beiden scheinen
unvereinbar
[Musik]
das maßlose
bis an die atlantikküste sind es zwar
nur knapp 30 minuten aber für ausflüge
ans meer hat die bauernfamilie visa in
frankreich bisher kaum zeit
bald ein jahr ist es her dass alexandra
und sandro mit ihrem sohn jan die
schweiz verlassen haben
[Musik]
im aargau hatten sie einen kleinen hof
mit gut 50 tieren hier sind es über 400
bei so vielen tieren ist die geburt
eines kälbchens fast alltäglich
in der regel können die kühe ihren
nachwuchs ohne unterstützung zur welt
bringen
obama muss man sozusagen traurig wenn
man sie dann im weg sind dann machen ist
dann den gruppenantrag
antrag auf wir schauen aber
dazu
zeit ist knapp und um die viele arbeit
bewältigen zu können setzen die visas
vermehrt auf technische hilfsmittel
[Musik]
alexandras neuestes gadget ist ein
elektrischer milchwagen
[Musik]
und noch etwas ist einfacher in
frankreich alexandra und ihr mann sandro
arbeiten besser zusammen
das kalb hat sich verdreht sandro muss
bei der geburt helfen
es geht nicht alleine jetzt muss auch
alexandra ran
[Musik]
trotz routine eine geburt ist immer auch
ein bewegender moment
und wirtschaftliche notwendigkeit
zugleich denn nur so können die wieses
ihre milchproduktion am laufen halten
[Musik]
in florida macht waffelbäckerei keinen
großeinkauf und für einmal ist seine
einkaufsliste noch viel länger als sonst
dachte man jetzt braucht das größte
festival in amerika und
müssen oft nur worte deuten sie 49
andere ausstellung los geht's tritt
wochenende waren ein anwalt und das
ganze im auge
[Musik]
mike ist heute doppelt gefordert er muss
das tagesgeschäft erledigen und
zusätzlich sieben kübel teig verbacken
das ergibt 200 waffeln für das dessert
festival zu dem sie eingeladen sind
die richtung für strom
[Musik]
mikes problem er muss den event eine
vorbereiten seine frau marina ist krank
mit starkem husten lag sie die halbe
nacht wach
[Musik]
doch kaum begonnen
wird mike immer wieder durch kunden
unterbrochen
[Musik]
geht es in diesem tempo weiter wird mike
heute kaum fertig
[Musik]
zum glück aber kommt
sie hat sich kurzfristig bereit erklärt
zu helfen und dalian ist eröffnet dort
wo sie
sich zu zweit die manager
definieren was man
normalerweise arbeitet dann im büro als
buchhalterin
dann meldet sich marina sie war
unterdessen beim arzt
euro schätzte
aber noch nicht lang an entzündlich
wird sich glaub das machen wir morgen ab
sagt
marina hat eine schwere bronchitis jetzt
müssen die auswanderer entscheiden ob
sie die teilnahme im bisher festival
morgen unter diesen umständen
durchziehen wollen
über dem agriturismo in der toskana
ziehen immer dunklere wolken auf
die stimmung zwischen eva und ihrem
ehemaligen partner philipp ist
unterkühlt
die beiden sprechen nur noch das
nötigste miteinander
kraske sich wirklich lieben froh dass
ich meine dass das mehrere caspers
intensive schulung klar
dass er auch als kläger machen und dann
hat mich macht es funktioniert nicht
philipp und eva haben sich zuerst privat
und dann geschäftlich auseinandergelebt
die gemeinsame vision ging verloren
durch wirklich nicht meine tage treffen
um tageshälfte
und
darum vernünftige
talseite nein auch jetzt noch mit
ja
am ende sind es zu viele unstimmigkeiten
die sich auftürmen schon bei der wahl
der liegenschaft hatten die beiden
unterschiedliche meinungen auch beim
tempo der umsetzung oder der frage der
finanzierung lagen die vorstellungen
weit auseinander
[Musik]
nur in einem sind sich eva und philipp
einig so kann es nicht weitergehen es
gibt plan er kaufte mir ob mit
irgendwelchen äste oder was auch immer
vor dem
wetter jedenfalls kaum chronik die
zweite variante ist dass man sich einen
teilverkauf machen wo über daher kongos
geschaffen und gut als bewirtschafter um
ihren teil vom geld gibt und dann quasi
frühjahr oder 34 jahren berichtete
zurückzahlt und
die dritte möglichkeit ist dass ich
übernehme
diese leute ja
egal ob er den posten des gutsverwalters
von philipp übernimmt oder die
liegenschaft verkauft einer von beiden
wird schon bald seine koffer packen
besser läuft es auf dem hof lah sowie
nahe der französischen atlantikküste war
sandro investiert weiter in seinem
betrieb er will die tiere von einem
außerhalb gelegenen stall neu auf seinem
gelände unterbringen dafür lässt er
bauen
die
kripo warnt die
ba mit der spanischen zeitung la cruz
ist der 8
wenn sandro alle tiere hier auf dem hof
beisammen hat keine effiziente
wirtschaften die idee ist eigentlich das
was man sich von ihr vor allem
futtermischwagen
davon ab
ob man daraus immer noch nie höher und
das immer noch tief und
mutter nach liebe gerade
[Musik]
pauli verständigen da für mich
also bitte frau
[Musik]
gbagbo
trotz der vielen arbeit alexandra
scheint in ihrer neuen heimat angekommen
zu sein
[Musik]
honig ist auf die versicherer und krieg
dass ein betrieb aus
fleisch sagt ihre kunst kuckuck
womit schon alles gesagt
[Musik]
hui
north korea
auch sohn john hat sich schnell
eingelebt der hof ist für ihn ein
riesiger abenteuerspielplatz
[Musik]
noch vor einem dreiviertel jahr konnte
der neunjährige kaum ein wort
französisch
jetzt spricht er bereits besser als
seine mutter alexandra
das ist so schnell im griff hat die
jungen
schon erste den ich aber
dass ich so richtig englisches problem
[Musik]
das gesagt nicht gut
da
[Musik]
und klappt das ganz gut
beide haben
die touristen sind weg und an den im
sommer überfüllten stränden in der
toskana ist wieder ruhe eingekehrt
erst ein halbes jahr ist es her seit
philipp ausgewandert ist eigentlich wäre
jetzt der moment um nach einer ersten
saison bilanz zu ziehen
doch der traum vom leben in italien
scheint für philipp zu ende zu gehen
bevor er richtig begonnen hat
auch eva hat sich alles anders
vorgestellt
[Musik]
für die kindergarten lehrerin sind die
herbstferien zu ende sie muss zurück in
die schweiz in den nächsten wochen soll
sich zeigen wie es mit dem agriturismo
weitergeht
eva und philipp waren erst zweieinhalb
jahre ein paar als sie das projekt
gemeinsam starteten
beherzt wollten sie dem buch des lebens
ein neues kapitel hinzufügen
es ist das hier funktionieren oder ich
weiß nicht was das leben ja jetzt
gesehen konga getan hat als
zweiter war gut die idee ein wo gut die
gute dinge
guten draht zum land hand und so wieder
abrufen
sollten körper kaputt sollte
trotz pensionsalter wagte philipp den
neuanfang denn im land seiner großeltern
fühlt er sich wohl ich habe mich morgens
im bunde
die olivenbäume die gegend liter und
sowie der tatsache dass es nicht
fertiggebracht haben
der inklusions muss man nicht an für die
gegend und führt das projekt
einfach überspringen so dass nicht mehr
fertig gebracht und da nicht versagte
dem sind das ist
und ich muss es irgendwo im moment
wirklich relativ teuer zahle
die letzten paar tagen pro woche ist
einfach so
dass ich versucht haben mich immer mehr
entfernen will so sprießt wird das
möglich sein
[Musik]
wenige wochen später erkrankt philipp
und er sieht sich dadurch gezwungen sich
aus dem projekt in der toskana zurück zu
ziehen
[Musik]
marina hat sich entschieden an dem
festival teilzunehmen
die medikamente und cortison
und
[Musik]
freundin dahin wird die beiden
unterstützen
auf geht's richtung stadtrand von tampa
in einer messehalle finden die des
servers stolz laut veranstalter das
größte das sehr festival der usa
50 verschiedene
süßwarenhersteller wetteifern heute um
den titel des champions
ich glaube
es ist riesig freuen der coole platz
bevor der markt vor dem hafen
marina und mike müssen 100 waffen herzen
vorbereiten als kostprobe für besucher
und jury
[Musik]
bevor es losgeht schnell noch ein blick
auf die konkurrenz
[Gelächter]
wenn es sich diesen ersten
erfolg dass man
es ist halt so
[Musik]
warum
das war wirklich getrennt
10 jurorinnen und juroren bewerten die
unterschiedlichen süßspeisen
speziell zieht gross tritt und
dann geht es richtig los
2000 der fans haben sich tickets für die
veranstaltung gekauft
auf der veranstaltung wollen die
schweizer er waffel angebot bekannter
machen ihr plan scheint aufzugehen
die konkurrenz um den titel beste surf
champions ist groß
zwei preise werden am ende des events
vergeben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die preise gehen an andere mike und
marina sind nach einem tag mit vollem
einsatz geschäft
bemerkt dass die amerikaner ja
jesus auch
gemerkt dass sie auf die süßigkeiten auf
das erstellen und das
negativ sehen wir tun sicher dass am
15 und messi innerhalb von
15 jahren
[Musik]
ärger zwischen
rose
baur sandro ganz ökonom hat sich einen
automatischen futter anschieber
geleistet
durch den roboter spart er nicht nur
zeit seine tiere bekommen auch mehr
futter und somit steigt der milch
vertrag
[Musik]
durch den kauf des riesigen hofs lee
sowie wurden die visas quasi über nacht
zu einem der größten milchproduzenten
der gegend
die vorbesitzer blieben als mitarbeiter
auf dem hof
das war teil des deals
patrice rondo der mittlere der drei
brüder half sandro vor allem in der
anfangszeit
[Musik]
patrice wird auf dem hof bleiben bis zu
seiner pensionierung in zweieinhalb
jahren
der jüngste der brüder war vor dem
verkauf für die zucht zuständig er
kümmert sich weiterhin um die kühle und
das merken
kritik und die vogue und wie die truppe
schuss ganz genau was er macht
durch den umzug mit ihren tieren nach
frankreich setzten die visa es alles auf
eine karte
hier an der atlantikküste erhoffte sich
sandro mehr unternehmerische freiheiten
sicherlich ein buch voller geld sollten
die gewisse bereiche um das klima an die
witterungsverhältnisse
adaptieren aber durchwegs positives und
ein riesen vorteil haben dass man mit
der fortsetzung zu verschaffen oder dass
wir das schaffen können sich besucher
über so
aber das sind natürlich herrscht vorne
im modal und
elizabeth ii also ich muss dir
hier die vierte vorgang und die auch die
abläufe sondern muss ihnen zu sprechen
dass man wieder einen schritt nach vorne
kennerin
große technologien sich das sind diese
geschichte wo
und wie machen wir schon
mit einer klatsche habe aber im
übersichtlichen rahmen und recht dass
man sagt wurden in schwaig sie
schon viele schlachten können labore
gehört sicherlich nicht dazu
[Musik]
haiders
familie visa hat ihr schicksal
erfolgreich in die eigenen hände
genommen und ihr glück in frankreich
gefunden
[Musik]
winterthur anfang januar 2022
sei sie das adobe
sie könnten mit
rund zwei monate ist es her dass sich
evas ehemaliger partner philipp aus dem
projekt in der toskana zurückgezogen hat
ist gut etwas
nach reiflicher überlegung hat sich eva
nun dazu entschlossen das agriturismo in
italien zu verkaufen
natürlich sah durch die toni der tu nix
7 und das
elektronikmärkte wir sind andere ist
auch wichtig wo die nicht vorhanden sind
und von den text
vor ich mache und hanni wie schön ich
seh das ist
offen sein und immer wieder neues
ausprobieren das macht für eva das leben
aus und wenn es schiefgeht versucht sie
das positive aus den gemachten
erfahrungen mitzunehmen so auch aus dem
auswanderungs projekt mit philipp
fischerei erprobt die partnerschaft das
hat ganz viele fragezeichen
und
das wird ihm so machen
also ich denke dass ich würde ihm sagen
so bin ich wahrscheinlich einteilen
archiv im sinn von thales group immer
alles gut
dass ich vielleicht doch einfach genau
hierauf mini gibt es auch keine linear
getriebe des minergie p er muss los und
ja
alles begann damit dass eva einen teil
ihres riegel hauses in winterthur
verkaufte damit finanzierte sie die
liegenschaft in der toskana
schon kurz nach dem start ging die
beziehung mit ihrem partner philipp in
die brüche
auf freundschaftlicher basis versuchten
sie das agriturismo zum laufen zu
bringen eva als geldgeberin philipp als
gutsverwalter doch zu unterschiedlich
waren die vorstellungen zu groß die
probleme aber auch wenn es diesmal nicht
geklappt hat das thema auswandern ist
für die 67 jährige noch längst nicht
abgeschlossen vor mir nicht vorstellen
moskau ganz viel witz lassen
und was mache ich also das ist mir
einfach schauen wie liegt dass ich mir
da bin ich mir gefordert da bin ich mit
aer lingus
machen und zwar so lange wie nicht
auskommen und wenig kraft haben und ihre
familien mit einfacher machen
[Musik]
gegen die
schönsten frauen krieg dass das ab
sonntag 14
in tampa genießen marina und mike einen
freien nachmittag am meer
bei zwei jahre leben sie bereits in den
usa eine zeit die durch viel arbeit und
den aufbau ihres waffe restaurants
geprägt war
uns immer klar - wandern und das neues
business start war jahr wird heftig aus
wie die schweiz also ich bin im entry
standard gebracht und nach immer mehr
freizeit aus dem spitznamen der technik
gelingt mit silikon aber dass station
mannheim und einfach
sanitäter
dazu gehört sich meine freizeit eine
geschaffen dann haben wir die fehler
nicht merken jetzt
auslöffeln
aber nicht jetzt ist rio
marina und mike wagten viel als sie die
schweiz verliessen
[Musik]
die krone krise erschwerte ihnen den
start
schließlich konnten sie ihr waffel
restaurant eröffnen das geschäft lief
immer besser aber die hohe
arbeitsbelastung machte mike krank
mit durchhaltewillen und zuversicht
haben sie auch diese krise gemeinsam
gemeistert
[Musik]
gebracht
oder einfach
sind angeschmissen stärker wurden
durcheinandergeschüttelt schwächen von
armee und trifft sicher und gut
füreinander agieren wie man weiß ist
unter anderem als limit und jetzt bin
ich jetzt muss ich also vertreten
was ich sehr viel gemerkt dass ich das
ist erstaunlich
am ende wurde die ausgestaltung des
jahres gemacht hat
konnte er mache nicht jeder vor der tat
meine fehler vor allem einige kennt wie
stark das ja eigentlich
[Musik]
allen schwierigkeiten zum trotz haben
sich marina und mike in florida etwas
aufgebaut und prozent
[Musik]
ich meine jetzt nicht da wo wir jetzt
sind mir hat es wenigstens probiert also
sehr schöne das so dass man dann versagt
hat und wer an diesem tag ist im labor
und für das stimmt dass wir uns wenn der
wagen mit vier stimmen dann hat er schon
lange andere war geschlagen
[Musik]
irgend eigentlich offen schon spricht
einiges
[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobile
versicherungen und vorsorge